[Music]
right now you're probably sitting down
to watch this video and staying seated
for a few minutes to view it is probably
okay but the longer you stay put the
more agitated your body becomes it sits
there counting down the moments until
you stand up again and take it for a
walk that may sound ridiculous our
bodies love to sit right not really sure
sitting for brief periods can help us
recover from stress or recuperate from
exercise but nowadays our lifestyles
make us sit much more than we move
around and our bodies simply aren't
built for such a sedentary existence in
fact just the opposite is true the human
body is built to move and you can see
evidence of that in the way it's
structured inside us are over 360 joints
and about 700 skeletal muscles that
enable easy fluid motion the body's
unique physical structure gives us the
ability to stand up straight against the
pull of gravity our blood depends on us
moving around to be able to circulate
properly our nerve cells benefit from
movement and our skin is elastic meaning
it molds to our motions so with every
inch of the body is ready and waiting
for you to move what happens when you
just don't let's start with the backbone
of the problem literally your spine is a
long structure made of bones and the
cartilage discs that sit between them
joints muscles and ligaments that are
attached to the bones hold it all
together a common way of sitting is with
a curved back and slumped shoulders a
position that puts uneven pressure on
your spine over time this causes wear
and tear in your spinal discs overworks
certain ligaments and joints and put
strain on muscles that stretch to
accommodate your backs curved position
this hunched shape also shrinks your
chest cavity while you sit meaning your
lungs have less space to expand into
when you breathe that's a problem
because it temporarily limits the amount
of oxygen that fills your lungs and
filters into your blood around the
skeleton are the muscles nerves arteries
and veins that form the body's soft
tissue layers the very act of sitting
squashes pressurizes and compresses and
these more delicate tissues really feel
the brunt have you ever experienced
numbness and swelling in your limbs when
you sit in areas that are the most
compressed your nerves arteries and
veins can become blocked which limits
nerve signaling causing the numbness and
reduces blood flow in your limbs causing
them to swell sitting for long periods
also temporarily deactivates lipoprotein
lipase a special enzyme in the walls of
blood capillaries that breaks down fats
in the blood so when you sit you're not
burning fat nearly as well as when you
move around what effects does all of
this stasis have on the brain
most of the time you probably sit down
to use your brain but ironically lengthy
periods of sitting actually run counter
to this goal being stationary reduces
blood flow and the amount of oxygen
entering your bloodstream through your
lungs your brain requires both of those
things to remain alert so your
concentration levels will most likely
dip as your brain activity slows
unfortunately the ill effects of being
seated don't only exist in the
short-term recent studies have found
that sitting for long periods is linked
with some types of cancers and heart
disease and can contribute to diabetes
kidney and liver problems in fact
researchers have worked out that
worldwide inactivity causes about 9% of
premature deaths a year that's over five
million people so what seems like such a
harmless habit actually has the power to
change our health but luckily the
solutions to this mounting threat
are simple and intuitive when you have
no choice but to sit try switching the
slouch for a straighter spine and when
you don't have to be bound to your seat
aim to move around much more perhaps by
setting a reminder to yourself to get up
every half hour but mostly just
appreciate that bodies are built for
motion not for stillness in fact since
the video is almost over why not stand
up and stretch right now treat your body
to a walk
it'll thank you later
you
[Music]